bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous
alors jean castex nommé à matignon
est ce que c'est une surprise alors
c'est la personnalité est une surprise
mais pas disons les règles qui ont fait
le casting
je m'explique emmanuel macron semble
vouloir eux être l'hyperprésident pour
le temps de sa fin de mandat
il a donc pris la personnalité la plus
tenue la plus terne et la plus disons
est la plus apte à entrer dans son
objectif de réélection qui est une
progressive absorption de ce qui reste
de l'appareil des républicains c'est à
dire principalement les élus locaux dont
et dont d'ailleurs castex ferons pas
fait partie et disons tous les clans qui
reste après avoir eu le juppéiste
edouard philippe là il a le sarko
fillonniste que en plus d'avoir été
collaborateur de nicolas sarkozy il
avait pris fait et cause pour françois
fillon
donc le le président continue non le
fait qu'il veuille une politique de
droite ou de gauche ans et emmanuel
macron ne va certainement pas de
politique du tout il veut se positionner
comme un parti de centre droit pour sa
réélection qui l'espère nécessairement
face à marine le pen est face à une
disons un retour sous des couverts
écologistes des d'une dynamique du nom
d'une dynamique du de l'ancien parti
socialiste alors cette nomination qui
est assez bon qui a provoqué plusieurs
réactions
jean castex est passé par le cabinet de
xavier bertrand
il est proche de nicolas sarkozy
également il a été à la délégation
interministérielle aux rassemblements
sportifs ils avaient été missionnés au
plan de déconfinement par emmanuel
macron est ce que finalement il a les
épaules et low profile pour tenir ce
genre de poste il a le parfait profil
pour un fusible
mais il n'a pas la légitimité autonome
qu'il faudrait qu'il faudrait en théorie
d'après notre constitution
pour un premier ministre là on est on
est haut face à un phénomène de deux
temps long qui a débuté sous nicolas
sarkozy est qu emmanuel macron a
terriblement accentuée qui est la
disparition du premier ministre qui je
vous le rappelle constitutionnellement
dire il mène la politique du
gouvernement et on est responsable
devant le haut devant les chambres et il
le petit à petit ça a débuté sous
nicolas sarkozy
ça s'est accentué particulièrement dans
la période
héros de hollande et sous emmanuel
macron c'est flagrant
il y a ce qu'on appelle à bien à tort
une hyperprésidence mais qui est en
était le nom présidence où le président
de la république est une sorte de
candidat perpétuel omnipotent omniscient
omniprésent ce qui est ce qui n'est pas
l'esprit de la vème république
d'où le fait d'avoir un premier ministre
terne je pense qu edouard philippe
prenait trop d'ampleur depuis
certainement les premiers or qui a eu
entre les deux hommes à la au début de
la crise des gilet jaune vers novembre
edouard philippe prenait trop de place
et là on est au moins sûr que plus
personne ne fera dont bras jupiter est
de retour pour commenter cette
nomination de jean castex avec
pierre-yves rougeyron alors avec un
directeur de cabinet de nouveau avec un
directeur de cabinet du nouveau premier
ministre est classé à gauche en
l'occurrence nicolas révèle quels
messages variables macro veut-il faire
passer vous alors il veut faire passer
deux messages premièrement il veut faire
passer à 10 ont toute une partie de la
technocratie qui était l'énarchie de
droite qui soutenait qui a soutenu
emmanuel macron depuis le début on
quittait les hommes qui étaient autour
d'edouard philippe donc particulièrement
des chiraquiens des juppéiste quelques
villepinistes que tout change pour que
rien ne change c'est à dire qu'en marche
reste une tendance de centre droit et se
positionne au centre droit donc si vous
voulez l'ancienne udf entraîné et il
envoie un autre message disons à la
gauche libérale en moi dire strauss
kahnienne pour aller vite mais qui elle
a contribué
faire élire dont étaient issus ses
premiers conseillers ce qu'on appelait
les mormons et qui à l'exception de ces
bêtes ndiaye ont quasiment tous disparu
et que là aussi tout change pour que
rien ne change donc qu' il n'y ait pas
de mouvement de la gauche libérale verts
l'espèce de vortex qui est en train de
se créer entre les écolos un renouveau
du ps et cetera
en réalité emmanuel macron veut tenir le
statu quo mais ne plus avoir dans son
camp une personnalité dont la popularité
commençait sérieusement à le gêner et là
pour le coup il a choisi certainement le
le le disons le le disons le l'homme
lige parfait jean castex est nominé
enfin il est nommé premier ministre à un
moment assez délicat qu'elle vous et
quelles vont être les enjeux il ya cette
relance économique il ya toutes ces
questions notamment à liés à l'épidémie
du du coronavirus quelles vont être les
les enjeux pour cette rentrée alors et
c'est là d'ailleurs la principale tâche
dans le cv du personnage est d'ailleurs
l'équipe pas suffisamment commenté c'est
que c'est l'une des personnes qui si il
y à des sanctions politiques où il va
devoir les gérer des sanctions
politiques du coronavirus et de la
gestion hasardeuse sinon catastrophique
de la pandémie comme du déconfinement
dont il a eu directement la charge est
aussi une part de responsabilité
vu qu'il ya plusieurs disons procédures
en cour pénale pour une partie de
l'ancienne équipe gouvernementale
donc il va déjà devoir affronter ça il
va devoir affronter les débuts de
campagne disant de 2022 d' emmanuel
macron qui ne vont pas tarder et il va
devoir également gérer une des pires
crises économiques que la france ait
connu avec des moyens de souveraineté
extrêmement limités avec une volonté de
maintenir la casse antisocial pour
complaire à une partie de
de là une partie du bloc éditeurs qui
est derrière emmanuel macron intacte
d'où les références aux retraites et ses
acquis qui se sont fait jour ces
derniers temps retour de la loi sur les
retraites
il va devoir gérer tout ça et prendre ça
sur lui pour que le président arrive
suffisamment intacte dans la campagne
électorale
il est donc disons qu'il a signé pour le
transpirer à matignon et il va beaucoup
transpiré est-ce que ça va être très
difficile pour lui d'être le disant le
bouc émissaire du président est l'homme
qui va être chargé d'être le beau gilet
pare-balles du président pendant les 2
les deux années à venir
j'arrive rougeyron la vue des français
qui sont pas forcément au courant de
petits et un jean castex on va revenir
un petit peu sur edouard philippe qui a
remis sa démission à la démission ce
matin c'était attendu est ce que selon
vous cette annonce elle signifie que le
edouard philippe va peut-être se
présenter à la présidence en 2022 alors
on lui prête et on prête encore de bien
plus qu à lui aux équipes gipn qui sont
autour de lui de le pousser
il est tout à fait possible il part en
tout cas au bon moment pour pouvoir
organiser sa campagne
le vrai problème d'edouard philippe va
être de se différencier de d'emmanuel
mac ronde va être de se retirer ce
sparadrap du capitaine haddock qui est
d'avoir été
avec emmanuel macron dans les pires
moments du maquereau nisme donc la
gestion cataclysmique de la pandémie la
répression anti populaires des gilet
jaune d'avoir éponger un certain nombre
d'affaires de la majorité également s'il
arrive à ça et à trouver un angle
politique parce que le problème c'est
qu'il ait 200 lui c'est qu'il est disons
de centre-droit disons sur un fou sur un
positionnement très très bon héros si
vous voulez le trait juppé berrou ligne
juppé berrou comme emmanuel macron s'il
arrive à trouver un angle pour se
présenter il y là disons le il a le cv
et il a le une part de popularité qui
peut lui permettre de s'opposer au
président il est d'ailleurs dans le
champ de ruines qu'est la vie politique
française
l'un des seul adversaire sérieux à
l'instant t et encore faudrait-il qu'il
en est réellement vie d'emmanuel macron
car ils mangeront vous êtes avec nous
pour commenter à cette nomination jean
castex qui remplace edouard philippe
cette décision vous l'avez dit aller à
lourdes de sens est-ce que selon vous
c'est une manière pour le président la
république de confirmer son ancrage à
droite c'est une manière 200 créé à
droite et surtout de de refaire sont six
volets son bloc présidentiel pour la
campagne parce que avant tout la mn
emmanuel macron ne fait pas d'eux ne
remplit pas les affaires courantes ne va
pas gouverner pendant deux ans il est
déjà en campagne électorale et il a mis
dix on a une sorte de grand secrétaire
général qui va gérer pour lui les
affaires courantes pendant que lui va
planifier sa campagne politique et sa
campagne politique se fera par
l'absorption des forts de dd force de
des forces de droite qu'on appelait dans
le temps droite oriane si vous voulez de
droite libérale le parce que il a en
face de lui une gauche qui rackettent en
train de demuth et du moins dans les
discours beaucoup plus que dans les
faits qui s'est ressaisie d'abord aux
européennes puis aulas est très marquée
aux municipales ou en marche ne verse
pas et ne s'enracinent pas et donc il a
besoin de l'ancrage local des partis de
droite et des républiques et en
particulier et il doit disons faire une
au pead su le plus vite possible
jean castex y est nommé premier ministre
et qui va remplacer edouard philippe il
va être il devra normalement d'ici
quelques jours
former un nouveau gouvernement selon
vous pierre-yves rougeyron et qui
pourrait perdre son portefeuille
ministériel
christophe castaner aujourd'hui ministre
de l'intérieur mais qui a été vivement
critiquée ces dernières semaines
alors il est il est possible que
christophe castaner n'est que si bête
tonnes de riz qui sont parmi les
derniers
disons les derniers grognards du
président en dix ans soit écarté 1 parce
que le 6 bat andy a beaucoup souffert de
ses propres déclarations pendant la
crise sanitaire et parce que christophe
castaner disons un bilan sécuritaire
tout à fait discutable le il est tout à
fait est possible que ces deux là
perdent je ne sais pas si des gens comme
jean yves le drian par exemple le
voudront être maintenue pour des raisons
là pour le coup plus personnel que
politique
je pense que il va falloir de toute
façon faire delà de la place pour tout
cas dans l'optique des manuels macron
pour quelques transfuges supplémentaires
du centre droit non un peu de la
tendance guillaume larrivé où des gens
comme ça pour justement commencé à
présenter le terrain sur les 12 % dont
sont disons créditer les républicains
dans les études d'opinion pour 2022
ils arriveront gérons à merci pour cette
analyse politique je rappelle que vous
êtes juriste et président du cercle
aristote